hello yes dr. Steve thank you for
calling how are you I'm good how are you
you want me to Skype in or that's okay
this is fine okay doctor how [ __ ] are
we not not as [ __ ] as as we could be
for sure you know the influenza pandemic
of 1918 which is this is different than
but it that was the biggest pandemic the
deadliest that I am on record killed 50
million people worldwide 1% of the
world's population which spent 99% of
people didn't die you know and so it's
the sort of magic of these giant numbers
of turn for us to imagine a hundred
thousand what's less 5 billion which was
the population of the earth of the time
but even though 99% of people didn't die
that still meant 50 million people
across the world died and that was
Spanish though that was the so-called
Spanish Plymouth right so this thing is
a little different in that kids are
being totally stared there's not been a
single death at least with the last data
that I got of any child under the age of
10 to coming to this disease or dying
from it and if your 10 to 19 years old
you get a quite 2% chance of dying 0.2%
I mean ninety-nine point eight percent
chance you won't die if I gave you those
odds
we were deaf you know you go to Vegas
and get everything you know so right now
it's still early even though it doesn't
seem like it but we're still gathering
information looking like the average
mortality on this thing is about 3% and
I'm writing the average because I'm 64
years old so the average mortality for
53 year olds or
3.6% and that seems to be thrown when
you factor in eighty years old have a
fifteen percent chance of dying and
four-year-olds ever 0% chance to die
when you average it all out subtree so
the way it looks is most people won't
get there and moat the vast majority of
people who do get it will not die that
being said out right now continue to
disrupt the F out of our lives for a
while there's no question about that are
the comedian's still considering doing
shows mentally ill they seem mentally
ill that they're all debating about
doing sure I mean it seems like guys
it's the [ __ ] it's the plague and
we're all talking about shows yeah well
I mean you got a live - that's the thing
and that's that's going to be hard for
this you're gonna have people who are
sick and they know they're sick and
they're gonna go to work delivering
foods for you know for grub for my squad
because they they got to make a living
and that's how some of this stuff will
get transferring you know there are
going to be people that will work
despite it that's why we have those
hepatitis day breaks every once in a
while because some pastry chef decides
does he need to work even though he's
got hepatitis day you know what are how
communicable is this in terms of it is
an airborne pathogen what does that mean
it lives in the air so all of these
masks don't do anything right and people
bump it down that's not really true
that's not really true
it's droplets so it's not really
airborne in the sense that it discovers
in the air so I've been using the
analogy you know if I'm standing in a
room and let's just say it's football
field-sized I'm the only person in the
room I'm standing in the middle of it
and I call I will spew out droplets
right and they will all have billions of
copies of this virus that they're just
waiting to specify but they will all
fall to the ground so if I call find you
and it ends up on your lip then you know
you would have wished
that you wore a mask at that moment you
were going to really wish that that
idiot that cost on you and cost a
droplet under your lip was the person
wearing the mask so if you get sick you
got to isolate yourself and you got to
wear the mask if you're out you know if
you're going to the doctor or whatever
so Massa no it hasn't people need to
wear so masks can help oh yeah they they
help the person who's infected from
transmitting it to other people so it's
what you're going to be in the hospital
when someone goes in the hospital
they're going to put if a medical
professional or a nurse but why I mean
there's a medical professional I mean if
any caregiver anybody comes into that
room they're going to have the patients
with their mascot
and that's relatively unprecedented for
droplet transmission but that's that's
the new thing that's coming down the
pike is have the patient put the mask on
when you walk in now you if you wear a
mask and you're asymptomatic you're not
a complete idiot if you're one of these
people who can't keep your dumb fingers
out of your mouth so the mass can be
helpful for you to prevent you from
sticking your fingers in your mouth and
your nose in your eye you know this is a
reminder you know how some people you
know I don't know cross their fingers to
remember something or whatever it's the
same sort of thing so it can be useful
for that to your right as far as just
walking around it's not going to do it
people are very contagious even when
they're asymptomatic this seems to be
one of the biggest problems you can be
alright you have a high viral load or
whatever it is even when you have no
symptoms so you're going out of
transmitting the disease to higher risk
people without even knowing it how do
you by going about your daily business
how do you fight that I mean that seems
to be something you can't really fight
other than just not going out no yeah
well it's tough when you have
asymptomatic transmission I was just on
another show and we were talking about
how we defeated smallpox in the way we
defeated smallpox was there were no
asymptomatic
someone got smallpox they were shedding
virus when they showed the the lesion
so you could go identify them and
vaccinate everyone around them and the
other thing that we had on our side was
the vaccine was very rapid act you know
it inferred immunity very quickly so we
went in vaccines everybody around and we
didn't have to vaccinate everybody in
the world we just had to vaccinate
around people that had the virus so that
we created a moat beyond which the virus
didn't crawl and the virus flied out and
we haven't had a case of smallpox in
decades in this world so that would be
much harder with a virus that has a
symptomatic transmission other words
where you can transmit it before you
know you're sick and so just yeah so the
way that you prevent it well you have to
let me let me answer that question so
the way that you fight it is universal
precaution whether you're around someone
who's sick or not
if you it's first off stop shaking hands
that it's a stupid tradition that you're
getting the only reason you do it is to
show that you don't have a weapon in
your hand that's the only reason we
started shaking hands it came from
medieval time so that it just let's just
stop that and start bowing to each other
or just way even the knuckle drop is too
much touching for me right once you
really bow to each other started this
whole problem but come on I know are you
right you're right you're right there's
no question that what you just said is
completely true but still any
unnecessary touching if you do touch
something anything because there's
droplets everywhere wash your hands
before you stick your dumb fingers in
your mouth and wash your hands before
you eat if you can't get Purell because
people have brought up cases of it I
don't know how much Purell they think
they need just open water will kill this
virus every time and cleaning surfaces
and those tend to anything any public
surfaces will if you sit down at a at a
table is totally cool that you know to
have them off wash it off before you sit
down that kind of stuff for that that's
you fight something that's not a
systemic transmission did you prevent
yourself from getting it if everybody
does that then we can really blow it
down now how far away do you think
something like a vaccine is possible for
this and how far away can we be from it
we're not that far away actually but the
problem is scaling it up right so they
synthesized well let me back up they
sequenced the genetic material for the
fight protein with the fight protein if
you've ever seen an electron micro
microscopy of a corona virus because we
gold spike and those spikes are the
things that attach to your cell and then
through that they inject their genetic
material into yourself emit brilliant
photography and if so they they sequence
that very quickly and then from that
sequence they were able to actually make
the protein so now we can make bacteria
just make the high protein it's harmless
by itself and that's your vector that
could be your vaccine if when you inject
that into people they form antibodies to
it and those antibodies then turn around
and prevent the virus from from
attacking ourselves and that would be
the hallmark of a of a successful
vaccine and we have the building blocks
right now that so we just make three
hundred and fifty million doses and
start handing it out to people now you
can't do that you got to test to make
sure it works you got to make sure safe
and then but say that they do that so
two months from now they showed that
they were able to prevent transmission
in a certain population of people that
got the vaccine now you're going to
scale this thing up so if you're going
to vaccinate let's say the whole country
then you have to have 350 million little
vials from the 50 million labels I mean
it this is not a trivial thing right and
if you're going to vaccinate the world
we're talking about 7 billion little
vials you know so what they'll do
initially it will vaccinate vulnerable
populations and they will vaccinate
around people like new Russia
they got a hundred cases there I heard
and they're sort of cordoning is getting
ready to cordon it off they would go
through and and vaccinate people that
has would have come in contact with
those people that's how they'll do that
so that way you don't have to vaccinate
everyone in the world right off the bat
flow the thing or thought that they said
that some people are estimating between
70 and 100 and 50 million people become
infected do you think those are accurate
numbers well okay so if we go into ten
percent that in the pandemic of
influenza that would be four ten percent
to be what seven hundred million people
right so that yeah is that right let me
see yeah let me ask let me ask my echo
echo what ten percent of seven billion
it's seven hundred million home yeah
yeah yeah I'm gonna say she fell yeah
yeah yeah nope so every time I go you
know has coronavirus you wreck I was
like doctor no well if we were on skype
you could hear her - yeah she'd answer
but yeah so that would be a pretty
astounding number of case you know the
worst case is we all get it and the word
then so seven billion people get at an
average mortality rates about three
percent that would completely overwhelm
all of the healthcare systems in the
world until there would be more deaths
than that just because of that so that's
the real issue isn't that the real issue
is we just don't have enough beds a lot
of people require hospitalization I mean
what are we doing right now is I mean I
guess we're just pumping money into this
but like do you think the US healthcare
system is ready to handle this now it
depends it depends on what happens in
the next month or two so if we have a
vaccine where they're testing an
antiviral called REM des aveer if that's
attractive it's in Phase three trials
right now which means we're giving it to
thousands of people right now and if it
works that will they'll fast-track the
[ __ ] out of that did
to hospital for the sickest people could
get them back out of the hospital to
make more bet no and then they just set
out of Italy that they had success with
a drug that was used to treat rheumatoid
arthritis
did somebody start okay breathing on
their own after they took that drug okay
yeah maybe and then I haven't heard of I
know there are there are several drugs
that they're trying there some HIV type
drugs there other antivirals that
they're trying on this so you know
they're really I'm gonna you know people
would politicize this thing right I got
to be honest with you I think our
government is doing what they can do you
know there's it's shut down the borders
they stopped travel from China they
pretty much gave one with this thing and
that all that can do is buy a time where
there's nothing we can do right now
short of a vaccine or an effective
treatment to stop this thing from doing
its thing but what we can do is I think
the South by Southwest thing was a smart
move you know why because in 1918
Philadelphia had a parade in the middle
of this influenza pandemic and it
exploded in Philadelphia you know it was
just exponential transmission whereas if
you look at other cities like New York
that had you know restricted from the
travel because a 1918 end even though
hardly knew what a virus was but they
had restricted travel and people are
self isolating you saw much more
measured increase in those cases and you
know if they were a lad but they were
able to let it smolder until it just
burned itself out you know so those
kinds of things make sense and you know
I'm supposed to Trey I'm supposed to get
on a plane on Saturday and go to Tampa
and I don't even know if it's even smart
to go but I'm not so worried about
getting there I'm worried about getting
back that's gonna do you or so on do you
foresee a situation where they ground
air travel I don't see it right now but
it's certainly if they if they start
showing that people have trans
in airplanes then yeah I think you'll
see that yeah or the airlines will just
do it just to be safe because yes this
bug actually doing it's a viral
pneumonia it's really [ __ ] up
people's lungs right that's right yeah
motors are notable yeah yeah the vast
majority of people will get symptoms
akin to a common cold okay we've all had
common colds at last a couple of weeks
right and coronavirus is one of those
viruses that causes the common cold
we've all had that this family of
viruses probably a dozen times in our
life and there's Rhino viruses which are
procore no viruses and there are these
corona virus and so there are three
three versions of this corona virus that
are known to cause serious illness
there's SARS MERS and then this code of
19 or code 19 isn't the name of the
virus the name of this virus is SARS CoV
- so sorry
regional partners this is the same
family of viruses they're all the same
they're the same yeah they're all corona
virus which gives us a little bit of a
head start because people were already
working on vaccines for SARS and MERS
and you know they're they're light years
ahead of where they would be if this
thing was truly completely a hundred
percent novel that we've never seen with
these right you know the fact that it's
a known family of viruses gives us a
little bit of heads up and this Ram is
dimma veer drug was originally tested in
sirs and mirth nations so if people are
again people have a common cold right
now are they what what are they and
they're panicking and freaking out what
do you tell them do you tell them to go
test it or there's not enough tests
that's right right well we want to test
people who are likely to have a moderate
risk of being positive Rachel you don't
want to tell somebody that has no risk
of being positive right because then
you're just getting a bunch of false
positives if you get any at all all
right now I've got the corona virus hang
on say sorry and this is allergies for
me and I gotta get on this plane with
these allergy
I know people are gonna be looking at me
my doctor Steve
this really is a stand this is the end
you're not even a real doctor and you
know so much no one has ever seen a
medical degree from you and and you
[Music]
don't don't flip out no fever cough
shortness of breath here is the one that
seems to be the most common thing is a
fever that's right right off and a fever
yeah yep yep and then they develop
shortness of breath but five to ten days
or and those folks that if it if it's
migrated from the upper respiratory
tract to the lower respiratory tract
those are the people who get in trouble
so they get a final pneumonia the body
mounts and the inflammatory response and
that inflammatory response doesn't help
anything when it comes to trying to
breathe right you know because it's
sweating fluid in there and there's all
these inflammatory what is the treatment
for this Wrangell goes it's just a flood
people anti-inflammatories and things
like that and sink and stuff like that
well yeah you know that that's a great
question
and you know there's some thought that
if you hit somebody with many
inflammatory maybe it would make them
better but it actually could accelerate
the growth of this virus because any
inflammatory sometimes will inhibit the
body's ability to fight off viral
infections so it should be very careful
about that right so right now the
treatment is supportive they put people
on a ventilator support their breathing
until the virus clears itself Wow it's
well dr. Steve I appreciate you calling
in and talking to us I mean it's really
kind of you know it's scary time well
it's scary in the sense that our lives
are going to be disrupted yes you know a
travel will be disrupted our jobs well
some of us are going to lose money
because they won't be able to work some
of us can
you know work from home right this would
be a good time for you to really ramp up
that punch but enlarge gatherings are
going to probably be a thing of the past
mostly like shouldn't that happen now
like why are you okay yeah you know what
my annual meeting i was going to the
american academy of austin started
medicine leading us has been canceled
medical meetings being canceled my
wife's business she had a national
meeting that's been cancelled south
myself was once a channel honestly
happiness are you immune to it we
certainly hope so that you know the
virus mutates you could get it again and
that would suck but norovirus note that
influenza does set you know that's why i
have to get a flu shot every year and
when we finally come up with a universal
influenza vaccine and that'll be the end
of influenza in this world but you know
they're they're very close to that we
may have had the next five years Wow I
mean but you should be if it doesn't
mutate you should be immune to this you
know those things you know only get
measles once that kind of right he's
crazy larger Steve thank you I mean it's
crazy but most most everyone will be
will be okay how old are you camp
I'm 35 35 you got a point two percent
chance of dying no I understand but I
also feel like doing shows comedy shows
right now seems crazy and stupid it's
crazier for the for the audience really
than it is for the comic now if you
somebody that eats the microphone I wear
the mic I would I would wipe off the mic
or bring your own mic and then make sure
when you touch the other life that you
wash your hands it's the air travel
everything seems unnecessary right now I
know you know it just seems like we
should it seems like we should just
chill for two months I'm okay with that
yeah I don't think that's a bad strategy
for could get everybody to do it I think
if we could get everyone to just chill
for two months that's the move I mean
faster talking about shows it's like
enough already the country yeah I feel
like I might be being selfish to going
on vacation on an airplane to Tampa this
week to happen break you think there's
like gondola guys in Italy that were
like we're not getting off the boat and
they're like yeah you're you selfish
[ __ ] don't know the whole country's
about the doctor you know all right
doctor well good luck out there it's
scary because it's unknown again 30,000
people in this country have died from
influenza this year no one bats an eye
well right no one bats an eye because
the military isn't in the street you
know it's like we look at Italy Italy
didn't get shut down for influenza III I
think that this I think maybe I guess
this is just a nasty bug and we don't
really know about it and then many of
the people in our country think it's
fake because they think the world is
flat and that they don't want to take
any precautions because they think it's
all pretend and they're like I don't
know what a body that's died of this so
that's the that's that's the mentality
of the American public so deserve a
plague more than our country and the
answer is now you know could any country
of disgusting people deserve a plague
more Cruzes you know we take $99 flights
on Spirit Airlines it's like I mean it's
just you know all right doctor thanks
for calling I appreciate it
you know I think you'll be fine Iran
will be okay ever just got to get
through the next I am pretty sure we'll
just get through the next few months do
you think the summer clears it up the
spring the summer the hot weather does
any of that help well you know that's a
good question it's in Australia though
and it's summer right now so we're
sitting right there great what about
people that are pregnant okay good
question they're the same risk as
anybody else
same razors you know with
feedeth no remains oh right yeah it's
not like Zika where if you get it you
know the something's going to happen to
the baby now you're saying spring/summer
doesn't move the needle that much no no
yet I mean how do we how do we know well
you know that it's in Australia and it's
pretty warm there right now
oh so it's in Australian it's warm there
yes so the spring of summer doesn't
[ __ ] matter yep
Tom Hanks just got it socks do you think
Tom Hanks okay do you think they'll be
okay
yeah yeah I mean Tom Hanks is probably
my age so he's got a 90 City because I
had strep throat I'm recovering from
strap
I took 10 days of six in the myosin or
clindamycin this is my father this is my
final day event I've been taking you
know mucinex and all that stuff I'm
gonna try to get off the mutant acts and
all that [ __ ] yeah I think that was
a good idea to not fly into New York and
do those shows sure sure Yeah right yeah
yeah you know that's the move all right
thank you thank you doctor quick good
night dr. Steve going to Tampa my kids
doing spring break I'm gonna go to Tim's
like you have your mind that's dr. Steve
folks won't be an Anthony we don't know
if he's a real doctor
but he seems to be he'll call me in a
prescription wherever I need one the
first time look up at South by Southwest
the first time I spoke to dr. Steve I
had a vicious cold in Austin Texas at
South by and I was heading into
bronchitis I needed a z-pack and dr.
Steve called me in a z-pack I tried to
get a difficult it sinus and my ID was
expired and they were all flipping out
and they're like you can't buy this
without a [ __ ] ID I'm like wipe you
know I mean it is it is while MBA
canceled the whole season you know I
mean this
this is crazy but that was our emergency
transmission dr. Steve hopefully that
answers some of your questions he seemed
to know what he was talking about knows
what he's talking about but it's all the
same [ __ ] yeah you know everyone says
the same thing it's like your chance of
dying is very low but enough people are
gonna die where it's gonna be a
nightmare right and you know nobody
really knows what your chances are until
you have the [ __ ] thing I mean
obviously statistically you can look at
the numbers but there's a lot of risk
factors that are specific to every part
you know so you know might be a good
time to stop the ciggies stop smoking
[ __ ] weed you losers literally stop
it clean it up don't legalize it put
them all back in jail it's true
it's enough already live it like an
animal yeah stop with the weed all the
time your lung capacity is gonna be
diminishing adaiah coronavirus because
you're high all the time I mean you
gotta start living right people have to
start living right
oh hey Vanessa thanks so much for taking
the call how are you how are you wait
don't say where I work I'm not gonna say
where you work but you were an emergency
room nurse right your nurse no well what
kind of what kind of nurse are you and
general medicine inpatient how are you
seeing a crazy influx of people coming
into the hospital thinking they have
coronavirus yes and it's so obvious when
they come in because EMS bring cement
and usually a mess just like has their
regular uniforms but when they learn
things them and they have like some
masks the down to cover up their shoots
they cover up their hair so it's like
automatic you know and the hospitals
like it's almost like mob mentality
where everyone's like freaking out about
it cuz I wasn't thinking about it so I
can't work and then you see everyone
bugging out and there goes knowing that
you know wear a mask so then it like
perpetuates that like anxiety have you
seen anyone with it and what do they
look like like what are their what are
they you know when they have this
disease what are their
some like what are they um so far no
one's been positive at my hospital so
far everyone is just like they're ruling
it out but it's just general like they
look sick they're coughing they have
like just they don't really have the
shortness about they put the body aches
it's very similar to the flu right they
don't look any different than a regular
patient
you just can't tell because of like how
they're dressed and how other people
bring to them in our dress what are what
is the test for coronavirus what do you
do is it ice just like a strap swab swab
yeah they swab your nose I think they do
they do like a full respiratory panel so
it's not just that but they're testing
for they're testing for other
respiratory issues Wow okay right what
is the what is the I mean are you are
you as a health care worker you like
paranoid that you're gonna get it no I
mean I'm what's about it than than most
people I know everyone else is really is
like on edge like there's actually
someone in my unit right now that
they're trying to rule it out and
everyone has to think because they're
like the virus going around with the
hospital and the doctors all these extra
precaution so it's a pity so let's say
someone does come in and they do
something on board they understand some
say like they come in and they
automatically put them in like in a room
by themselves we get a map they have to
wait we have to wear it down to go away
and we have to wear the maps and the ice
shield and then it's an automatic workup
and I'm actually not allowed to look on
the chart so there's like a privacy
thing where like if I go and like it's
gonna get fun like there's no reason for
me to be looking on oh so they're aware
you're not even allowed to know who's
got it and who doesn't know I'm that I'm
directly taking care of the patient
right okay mm-hmm that makes sense do
you think that we're equipped to handle
the influx of cases that are coming in
well no we're running out of supplies so
no I mean that's like a ration out so
you're running out of supplies already
day - yeah Ravi has a ration supplies -
all lost because people steal them
like people come in from other units or
people who don't need them since that
they need them so they'll come and take
them in and you get me at you make you
have no nurses who like I'm in people's
faces and they're coughing in my face
and I can't find a mask because we're
running out and so I get exposed to
things that I shouldn't be exposed to
because other people are selfish and let
people think they're gonna get it how
quickly do you think this is gonna
generate into a kind of a chaotic
situation when you're running out of
some lies it's not that serious the
YouTube clip is gonna say nurse in New
York City says they're already running
out of supplies NYC nurse says they're
already running out of supplies you
think people should chill out yeah
everyone everyone needs to and that's
what that but that was like tweeting the
whole like frosting out of supplies is
because people who don't need them start
getting them and then people who
actually do need them then then you
start running out but it's like no there
are much more things and the sort of
virus like but I'm exposed it's a brutal
disease the corona virus no it's not
it's a mild illness and most of all I
find this like yeah most of all are fine
like if you're healthy like you can get
better in a week with like
over-the-counter medication and if you
don't have Dyer people that are old and
people that are there things going on
with them right so it's like older
people are the ones that are dying no I
mean we're running on social security
anyways we're like we needed a new place
so that's one way to look at it you're
you're you're an Asian person right I
mean let's say we could just say that
let's just say that he's at a certain
point is it enough with the e2 the bats
and all that [ __ ] we just is it do we
start eating regular food what about a
turkey sandwich because isn't that where
a lot of these diseases are coming from
like you guys just keep eating you put
anything in a pot and just boil it it's
like and then you slurp it down it's
like at a certain point you know how
about a chicken singer you know rein it
in I mean that's what it is though it's
like these viruses I mean they come out
of Asia because you guys just don't
you'll eat anything
yeah well listen I appreciate it we
don't want to put you in a spot thank
you for calling we're we're we're
running you're running out of supplies
in New York City you heard it here first
on the Jill Dillon show have you seen
the military anybody from the government
in there yet no not yet military yeah
tell us about your friend and you were
so every day worried that he wouldn't go
watch a movie in a different
neighborhood and she won't be able to
come home bipolar my house is open but
that's in your restaurant with all the
long his friend from New Rochelle come
to your home why not because she's
probably sick all right focal I I
appreciate that I appreciate you
updating this updating us on this we'll
keep checking in with you throughout the
pandemic yeah the most important thing
that people can do right now is like and
subscribe to our YouTube channel so we
can get the truth out to you all right
Thank You Vanessa have a good night
folks that's where we're at you know
we're running out of supplies in New
York she's downplaying it she's probably
got a gun to her head it's probably a
[ __ ] guy with a girl with a gun to
her head right there go ahead timeout
tell him how unserious and all this tell
him how fun it all is tell him it's a
real big fun thing you know but you
heard it already they're running out of
because every drug addict in New York
City is running in
thinking they got Corona but that is
folks
bananas all right this is we're
delivering you the updates that you need
in real time these are the top experts
in the country the doctor from Opie and
Anthony and this girl my friend dates
these are the top experts in the country
right now dealing with the pandemic
we're bringing them on the program okay
these people know what's happening we're
getting the information to you
uncensored unrestricted how do you help
us you like you subscribe join the
patreon get in your house start
listening comedies over comedies
canceled you know thank you